why this is supposed to be easy so today
we're going to test our chopstick skills
I grew up up with chopsticks in my hand
because my parents really wanted me to
like learn how to use them so I feel
pretty confident I can pick any of these
ax it would be really fun to troll you
right now no I don't even think I know I
am confident in my chopsticks skills
pretty good at chopsticks especially
like eating the last pieces of rice from
a bowl I just like pick it up really
quick I would ideally want dice Tower
if I'm thinking what it is it's just a
bunch of die stacked on top that's gonna
be easy I'm prepared to do grain of rice
but I do not want to do dice tower that
is not something that is you know easy
to pick up I guess that's the whole
point of this game Rock Paper Scissors
shoot
alright let's go here we go
[Music]
oh this is really funny wait a grain of
rice
[Music]
hmm wasn't the one I was hoping for but
I think I'll do well you got to get it
like right
[Music]
okay I really like the green ones so my
strategy is to pick up the green ones
first
good luck YouTube my palms are sweating
so that means I'm ready Oh No Oh two
three four okay I got one actually so
much harder why six poor
[Music]
[Music]
No then I love him love him oh come back
maybe a new year
I don't want to try how could this
happen
yeah congratulations 20 and at 20 I was
five sure how long 65 I want to know
what this person is doing with their
life since that they managed to stack 49
and I still honestly could have probably
done more if I would look like a little
bit clumsy
I like knocked off at least three with
my mouth trying to put it in it was good
facing up again - you enjoy these
I love these bad boys it's like a
continual mastering of them which I
really appreciate this has only made me
more into chopsticks so much better and
then
[Music]